- So, hi, welcome, everyone.
It's my distinct pleasure
to introduce Erick White,
who I've known since
graduate school at Cornell,
and who many of you know
is one of the most distinguished scholars
of Thai Buddhism and Southeast
Asian Buddhism generally
working in North America right now.
Erick is an independent scholar
who has previously taught
at Antioch University,
Cornell University, and
the University of Michigan.
His research explores
the cultural politics
of popular religion in
Thailand, the subculture
and religious careers
of Bangkok professional spirit mediums,
and the social-cultural dynamics
underlying claims to
authority and charisma
in Theravada Buddhism.
He's the author of numerous book chapters,
and journal articles including
"Contemporary Buddhism, and Magic,"
"The Cultural Politics of the Supernatural
in Theravada Buddhist Thailand,"
"Rethinking Vernacular Religion
Across Mainland Southeast Asia,"
"Rethinking Anthropological
Models of Spirit Possession
and Theravada Buddhism,"
and "Fraudulent And
Dangerous Popular Religiosity
In The Public Sphere: Moral
Campaigns To Prohibit, Reform,
And Demystify Thai Spirit Mediums."
He's currently in the process
of drafting a book manuscript entitled,
"Spirit Possessions as Buddhist Vocation:
Reimagining Piety In Modern Thailand."
I think some of what
he'll be talking about
will be engaging with
the topics of that book.
So please join me in welcoming
Erick White for today's talk,
"Spirit Possession In
Buddhist Southeast Asia."
Erick.
- Okay, thank you, Erik,
for that introduction.
Thanks to the council for
inviting me to give a talk,
and for Chris managing the details,
and for everyone showing up digitally
from wherever you are in
the world and time zone,
I will share my screen.
So my talk today is actually about a book.
It's not my book in progress,
it's an edited volume that
just recently came out.
"Spirit Possession In
Buddhist Southeast Asia
Worlds Ever More Enchanted."
I contributed the afterword to it.
Basically, I do think
it's an important book,
groundbreaking,
I'll just say a few things
about initially why.
The scholars have been
working on spirit possession
in Buddhist Southeast
Asia for a long time,
but this is the first book
that has actually
brought scholars together
who have been studying
across different regions and countries
in Mainland Southeast Asia,
and putting their
observation and arguments
into conversation with each other.
It brings together
scholars who have worked
across the different
Theravada majority countries
in Southeast Asia, that's unusual.
It's also included in the
mix of scholarship work
on spirit possession in Vietnam,
that's even more unusual.
Work on spirit possession in Vietnam
is tended to be siloed in many ways.
And the book also brings together
multiple generations of scholars.
So the editors, Benedicte and Peter,
they began working and writing
about spirit possession
in the 1980s.
and Irene Stengs and I began working,
and writing on the topic in the 1990s,
but the remaining eight
scholars in the book
who contributed to the book
began working in either
the 2000s, or the 2010s.
So there really is a kind
of cross-generational cohort
sort of conversation going on in the book,
and that's unusual.
Basically, as you can see
from the table of contents,
there's like 10 case studies,
and then five out of work in Thailand,
two out of work in Myanmar,
two out of work in Cambodia,
one from Vietnam.
It's too bad there's
not more from Vietnam,
but there's sort of size limitations.
And then there's an introduction,
and then afterwords,
and both the introduction,
and the afterwords
in a sense
take the measure of the
different contributions,
and place them in terms of
the existing scholarship,
and then point towards pass forward.
My talk today is about the
book and its importance,
and the contribution it makes
to the ongoing conversation,
but there's some caveats.
My talk isn't simply a
recapitulation of the afterward,
and it's not a detailed
or exhausted discussion
of the book's content and
its particular chapters.
I wanna sketch a broader in general terms,
the intellectual value of the book,
and to make sense of it
and its contributions.
I wanna place the book in a larger,
and longer intellectual history
of the study of spirit possession
in Buddhist Southeast Asia,
and see the book as contributing
to an ongoing conversation,
and debate that's happened
across scholarly generations.
And as you'll see, I place
the work in this volume
in sort of what I term
the third generation of
scholarship on the topic.
And basically I'm gonna be talking about
the way empirical foci of
studies, the analytics, themes,
and the theoretical
conceptions have shifted
across those generations
in a kind of cumulative evolving way,
but I'm not suggesting
that later generations
simply replace the prior
generations topics and themes
and analyses, but sort of
layered and supplemented,
and sometimes with
agreement and disagreement.
The other qualification is I'm
leaving out for the most part
detailed bibliographic
and citational references.
I've mapped these scholarly
generational cohorts
in these sort of 20 year groupings,
which is obviously kind of artificial,
and I paint with a
necessarily broad brush.
So there are obvious exceptions
to some of the claims I'm making.
When I talk about spirit possession
in Buddhist Southeast Asia,
I'm talking about Mainland.
So I exclude Buddhism in
insular Southeast Asia,
and I also exclude discussions about
the geographic borderlands
of Mainland Buddhist Southeast Asia,
like Northern Malaysia, Southern China,
Bangladesh, even India.
And the other thing
is I'm not talking about spirit possession
in upland societies and cultures,
I'm talking about it in
lowland societies and cultures.
The conversation and debates
are a whole different beast
in terms of the uplands.
And there's likely a Thai-centric bias
to the kind of intellectual
history I'm going to give.
My discussion is mostly probably rooted
in English language scholarship.
So unlike my afterword,
I'm actually gonna talk a little bit
about the pre-history of the
study of spirit possession
in Buddhist Southeast Asia,
which is to say, there's
this first generation
that I see as starting
in around from 1965,
but the way spirit possession
and Buddhism was thought about
before this time period is important
for understanding what happens later.
It kind of haunts,
and even shapes the
kinds of conversations.
There's sort of foundational ideas
that are sort of laid down in dilemmas,
and they continue to reverberate.
And you'll see that's
part of the discussion
that I'm presenting to you.
I've tried to give
little descriptive tropes
for each of these sort of generations.
And in the case of the prehistory,
I talk about spirit possession
ignored or marginalized.
So, basically, in this earliest period,
spirit possession in general
has always been stigmatized
within both colonial
and post-colonial scholarship on religion.
It is seen as a remnant of the historical,
and civilizational precursors
to the world of historical religions.
People don't talk about spirit
mediums and spirit possession
being central to the vision
of the ethical good life,
and the practices and
how to gain transcendence
if you're a Christian or
a Muslim or a Buddhist,
or Judaism, or what-not,
in that sense spirit possession
has always been located as
a kind of relic, or survival
of a pre-world historical
religious imaginary.
And you can see that in many
common semantic associations
of spirit possession.
Shamanism, magic, divination,
superstition, animism, spirit cults,
these are all terms that
are circulated around it,
or sometimes can serve as replacements,
and they all sort of point
to a pre-world historic
religious imaginary,
and oftentimes spirit possession I think,
is seen as a kind of descendant,
or stepchild of Shamanism,
but this has created
a kind of foundational conceptual dilemma.
Spirit possession is always constituted
as radically other to and outside world
historical religions,
and this historical and
civilizational framing creates
this enduring dilemma
about how to understand the relationship
between spirit possession and
world historical religions.
Spirit possession tends to always look
like something illicit
which doesn't belong in a world religion,
but has been surreptitiously
smuggled into it.
And for scholars of
Southeast Asian Buddhism,
they've tended to conceptualize
this relationship,
and this belonging and this smuggling
through the lens of
this idea of syncretism,
which I will talk about along the way.
So you can see in this
earliest period of scholarship,
spirit possession has been
ignored and marginalized
in the study of Southeast Asian Buddhism
'cause scholars are
working on documenting,
and studying things that
were seen as more canonical,
widespread, and mainstream,
and spirit mediums and possession
didn't seem to have any
relation to these, right?
So making sense of monks and laity,
and their relations to each other,
making sense of monasteries
and temple life,
what is the Sangha, what is monastic life,
what's the renunciatory path.
Different kinds of rituals
and actions like meditation,
and merit-making and ritual cycles.
How to understand cosmology
and karma and rebirth.
How to understand Nirvana
and practical ethics,
and what the good life is.
For most scholars,
especially in the colonial,
post-colonial era, spirit
possession and spirit mediums
seem irrelevant to sort
of really making sense
of all of that.
So you can basically see
that sort of Buddhologists,
and religious studies scholars
who work with primarily,
sort of canonical literary sources
in Southeast Asia of Theravada Buddhism.
Those sources are silent for the most part
about spirit possession
and spirit mediums,
or they have negative
representations of them
in terms of malevolence
and inauspiciousness,
and beastly arts and things
that need to be exorcized.
And there's also no real
obvious institutional presence,
or significance of spirit
possession in the region,
which is different than Tibetan Buddhism,
which has State Oracles, right?
You have highly accomplished monastics
who are possessed by guardian deities,
and then the Dali Lama, and other figures
consult with these
possessed beings, right?
So there's nothing like State Oracles
in the Southeast Asian Buddhist tradition.
It's been marginalized by
historians and anthropologists.
There aren't many historical
references to spirit possession
in archival sources.
Their voices weren't recorded.
They didn't produce records
that were preserved.
Anthropologists have been
the ones who have recognized,
and focused on spirit possession the most.
And it makes frequent appearances
in anthropological studies,
but usually it's relatively brief
because they themselves, anthropologists,
are focusing on those same
kind of more mainstream
conventional sorts of topics.
And this is even true in later
generations of scholarship
after 1965.
There's an explosion of ethnographies
written by anthropologists about
Buddhism in Southeast Asia,
and usually discussions
of spirit possessions
sort of show up in a paragraph or two,
or some footnotes, or what-not.
The first kind of exceptions of this
came with anthropologists,
and anthropologists have been
the majority of the scholars
looking at spirit possession
in Southeast Asia.
There was an exception to the rule
in terms of even anthropologists.
And I see this as this first
generation of scholarship.
And I see it in this
era from 1965 to 1985.
And my trope is they
think of spirit possession
as this domesticated niche
within Buddhist Southeast Asia.
So there's basically three scholars.
Melford Spiro, who looked at possession,
and the Nat cults in Burma,
and Stanley Tambiah, who worked
on and studied possession
in the context of spirit
cults in Northeast Thailand,
and Thomas Kirsch who
worked on spirit possession
and sort of the Buddhist order
also in Northeast Thailand.
And there's not a lot of other scholars
who really sort of focus
in with much more depth
in terms of spirit possession
during this period,
but these are sort of primary sources
that people keep going back
to for reference points
in later generations.
So, basically, they've been
working in Myanmar and Thailand.
These seminal pieces or scholarship
aren't really centered in Laos.
Although, you can think
about Northeast Thailand
as sort of an ethnic
Lao sort of borderland
between Siam, or Thailand and Lao,
nobody is really from Cambodia.
These scholars focused on certain
empirical sorts of things.
They spent a lot of time elaborating
the ties of spirit possession
to pre-Buddhist religiosity,
and animism, and/or the spirit cults.
They saw spirit possession
as strongly emblematic
of the local folk religiosity found
in rural peasant society and culture.
They spent a decent amount of
time thinking about trance,
and how that related to other
kinds of ritual experiences,
but also looking at the ritual process
that spirit mediums took part
in and how it played out,
and the way it was part
of a ritual healing.
Spiro actually said,
his book is called
"Burmese Supernaturalism."
He said he could have titled
it instead, "Burmese Medicine,"
that's how closely he saw
these kinds of topics.
They all tend to look at spirit possession
and spirit mediums as providing
this narrow set of
mundane worldly benefits
that were really not...
They didn't see as provided
by Orthodox Buddhist actors
or activities, right?
So it's not just that you
don't turn to a spirit medium
for help in terms of gaining
liberation from Samsara,
or in terms of a better rebirth,
or even in terms of Samsara
like the kind of benefits you
could get from merit-making.
Instead it's narrower kinds of things
in terms of local concerns, right?
Violating norms about
belonging in kinship groups,
or in, like, village communities,
or sexual ethoses, and rules and whatnot,
or healing of particular
kinds of illnesses
that have been brought
about by maybe affliction
by malevolent beings and whatnot.
And the other thing they all talk about
is how these spirit possession
provides a sort of a stage
in which there's a kind of sanctioned
bacchanalian excess and pleasure,
and that this has a certain...
It's like a legitimate kind of violation
of conventional Buddhist norms
in terms of drinking and revelry,
and all this other stuff.
And they all, in various degrees,
map out how spirit mediums
are at one end of a pole
of a kind of segregated
structural opposition
from spirit mediums to Buddhist monks.
And they look at it
in terms of like, the kinds
of rituals they engage in,
the behavioral ethos, even their
presence on a ritual stage.
They will talk about
how Buddhist monks exit
then later spirit mediums will enter,
even if it's a kind of
conjoint ritual in some sense,
they're almost spatially
and temporarily segregated
in many ways,
and there's a reticence in
their kind of engagement.
Analytically, these scholars
are spending a lot of time
trying to make sense
of the character and
dynamics of Syncretism
which is related
and how these different
pieces sort of fit together,
how spirit mediums and spirit possession
sort of sits inside of a world
structured and dominated by
Buddhist values and principles.
They're also all to some degree
working with this question
of the great tradition
and the little tradition,
and how Buddhism as a world religion
has been localized in the region,
but also within agricultural communities.
They're all sort of trying to
map the total religious field
of these rural peasant villages
where they did their research.
Tambiah has this sort of famous map,
sort a four part map of
these different religious
sort of virtuosos, monks and mediums,
and the masters of vital
essences and exorcists,
and the different kinds of
rituals and performative,
and even material that
sort of spread out of that.
Kirsch tends to talk about
Buddhist and Brahmanical,
and animistic sort of divisions
in the religious field,
and how they're related
to each other, right?
And they're all sort of...
To a degree they focus on spirit mediums
and spirit possession,
in order to illuminate this larger puzzle
of how Syncretism works,
how localization works,
how the religious field works.
So their discussions of spirit
possession and spirit mediums
roots into that.
And they all approach these
from different kinds of perspectives
in the anthropological tradition.
Spiro has a kind of functionalist,
and he's a psychological, anthropologist
informed by Freudian kinds of thinking.
Tambiah is sort of more of a
British social anthropologist
informed by structuralist kinds of models.
Kirsch is an American trained
who's been formed by Parsons,
and his vision of sort of sociological,
sort of dynamics and structure.
And the way they conceptualize
spirit possession
in Southeast Asian Buddhism,
they tend to talk about it
in terms of like I said, syncretism.
Kirsch uses this language
of inclusive syncretism.
I've sort of tended to
add hegemonic on to that.
So spirit possession
is seen as hegemonically
dominated by Buddhism.
It's domesticated and constrained
in its practices and actions and scope
by Buddhist actors, and institutions,
and beliefs and practices.
There's even a sense,
especially from Kirsch
that historically spirit
possession has been...
If it is this remnants of a
pre-Buddhist kind of worldview,
it's been reconfigured over time,
and even fragmented in certain ways
so that it is ultimately subordinate
to Buddhist values, and goals
and frames of references.
And spirit possession,
therefore, is seen as essentially
kind of peripheral to
the normative mainstream
Orthodox Buddhist order,
and it provides these specialized niche
of unique, but relatively
marginal services,
activities, experience, and functions
for rural village Southeast Asians
when looked at from the frame
of what a Buddhist good life is,
and what moral practice is,
and ritual practices one should engage in.
And I just wanna emphasize here
these terms of like dominated,
constrained, subordinated,
peripheral marginal,
because not to sort of ruin the plot line
of the rest of the talk,
but you could see the later generations
in different ways, essentially
challenging this language,
qualifying it, maybe
pushing back even more
in terms of dismantling
it, or disagreeing with it,
displacing it, or even
inverting these kinds of claims
as they encounter spirit possession
in Buddhist Southeast Asia.
And the thing to keep in mind
is that the later generations
are encountering a different...
Spirit possession itself,
and spirit mediums are
changing in subsequent decades.
So the scholars are encountering
transformed visions of spirit possession,
and spirit mediumship, and
also they're encountering...
It's a totally transformed
kind of Buddhist world,
and broader social world as well.
The second generation I
see is this 20 year period
from 1985 to 2005,
and this is when basically
you're thinking about
the trope is spirit possession
as religious innovation within
Buddhist Southeast Asia.
So, Myanmar as a site of
study of spirit possession
in Buddhist Southeast Asia
fades in this era because anthropologists,
the primary people
studying this phenomenon,
obviously, for political reasons
have found it difficult
to get into the country.
And the one exception is
Benedict Brac de la Perriere
who wrote a book in many articles
on the cult of the 37 Nats
following in Spiro's footprints,
but other than that work sort of dwindles.
There's some historical work.
So the most the scholarship in this period
comes out of Thailand, frankly.
The topic still isn't on the horizons
for people working in Laos
or Cambodia the same way.
These studies are strongly
shaped by this intensifying
post World War II
transformation of Thailand.
It began before this period, right?
In the '60s, and then
essentially the '70s.
You have extensive rural urban migration,
exploding urbanization, a
rapid growth in education,
especially higher education,
the intensification of
capitalist development,
the growth of a professional middle class,
deepening democratization and
expansion of civil society,
burgeoning mass media,
intensifying nationalism,
and even the revival of the
monarchy, and all of these,
I won't go into the details,
but they also are fit into...
These are the forces
that are transforming spirit possession,
and spirit mediumship on the ground.
So, in terms of new foci that come up,
all of a sudden you see
a lot of these studies
talk about spirit mediums in cities,
the discovery of spirit mediums in cities,
like Chiang Mai, and Bangkol,
and Khon Khaen in particular.
Prior generations
didn't talk about spirit
mediums in cities.
These new generation
also really digs into...
The other thing about their scholarship
is unlike Spiro, Tambiah, and Kirsch,
their publications are
focused sort of exclusively
on spirit mediums and going into detail
about mediums and possession.
A lot of articles, no books.
So they go into unpacking the biographies
of individual spirit mediums,
and how individuals become spirit mediums
in much fuller kind of details,
taking apart hagiographies,
taking apart oral accounts
of how individuals
became spirit mediums.
There's also a lot of documentation
about how spirit mediums
sit at the center of,
and are embedded
within master-student
lineages of instruction
of various sorts with actual individuals,
and with mythic figures.
And this was not really discussed much
in the prior generations.
There's a lot of work
on how spirit mediums
sit at the center of, they
have an entourage of followers,
a network of patrons, circles of clients.
They have their own students as well.
And so sort of describing
and mapping that is important
for making sense of what
spirit possession is.
And sometimes these groups
even become more like
religious movements or cults
of like even kind of broader scale.
There's a lot of discussion
about the way in which
these sort of spirit mediums
found in cities are
following vocational careers.
Prior studies of spirit
mediumship in rural areas
would often talk
about how individuals
who become spirit mediums
would become possessed occasionally
during certain kinds of ceremonies,
or in certain kinds of crises,
certain kinds of annual cycles,
but the spirit mediums in these cities
are basically like, they're
hanging up a shingle,
and they are sort of
available to help people
like every week and sometimes
multiple days during the week.
So they really are sort of
like vocational careers.
They are often religious
careers of virtuoso,
in which that's actually a primary means
by which they're supporting themselves
in terms of livelihood.
There's also a discussion about
how there's growing numbers.
Everyone's talking about
how there's growing numbers
of them across the country
and within regions,
and the diversifying demographics of them.
There used to be the
notion that spirit mediums
were mostly women and/or
transgendered people,
but increasingly there's recognition
that there's cisgendered males
and other folks doing this.
So that's part of the
sort of the making sense
of who spirit mediums are and
what spirit possession is.
And there's also this overwhelming sense
that spirit mediums and
spirit possession itself
is newly assertive as a public presence,
and has a kind of prominence
in local settings,
and in the country,
both in terms of in person,
the kind of rituals they're
performing in public,
but also in terms of the mass media,
Thai language mass media picks them up,
looks at them, examines them,
they write their own sort of
accounts of their experiences,
and have those sort of
placed inside of mass media.
The image of spirit mediums
also focuses on how they forged
social financial and ritual relations.
Sometimes contentious,
sometimes idiosyncratic
with Buddhist monks, typically
with them as junior partners.
There's a lot more documentation
about how spirit mediums have
these sort of somewhat tense,
and complicated relationships
with particular monks
in this or that location or temple
engaged in joint kinds
of religious projects,
or ritual activity,
and that wasn't really emphasized,
or even present in the prior
generation scholarship.
And then there's just this general sense
that spirit mediums
are these innovative
religious entrepreneurs.
There's a lot of documentation
about these new kinds of gods
that are possessing them
that are drawn from the Chinese pantheons,
or Hindu pantheons, Indian pantheons,
pantheons of royal figures,
there's a lot of focus
on they're doing new kinds
of rituals and techniques,
some drawn from Buddhist actors,
some drawn from astrologers, what-not.
They talk a lot about
merit, Bon and barami,
sort of perfected virtue,
and other kinds of Buddhist terminologies
make sense of their
experience of possession,
and the power of the possessing deities.
These deities are seen as
repositories of Bon barami.
This is not the way people
talked about the kinds of spirits
that possessed figures in the
prior generations studies.
And there's a lot of discussion
about how these sorts of spirit mediums
display of behavior that
mimics normative ethos.
They're like vegetarians,
and they sometimes
display very prominently,
they're celibate, that
they engage in meditation,
that they sponsor merit-making activities,
and all this other sorts of elements
that make them look more
proper and normative and pious.
These spirit mediums are
also shown as sort of...
They're drawing on
mainstream Buddhist material
and visual cultures.
They make ambulates of the
gods that possess them,
they make statues of
the gods, and whatnot.
So they're sort of my more embedded
in the kind of visual
material performative culture
of Southeast Asian
Buddhism or Thai Buddhism.
Very quickly, the analytic themes.
There's this analysis of
how these spirit mediums
are remaking village
religiosity in the city,
either rural migrants who
have brought it with them,
or mobile urbanites
who have encountered it
in their travels around the country.
There's analyses
of how you basically have
an ethnic majority tie
sort of appropriating
and reworking elements
from ethnic minority religions,
like Chinese popular religion,
or Indian popular religion
in terms of their
religious self-identities,
and how they're appropriating,
and reworking royalist sacrality
even as they're non-royals
in the sense that they're possessed
by these sort of past royal past kings
and monarchs and royal figures.
There's always this sense
that these kinds of spirit mediums,
this kind of possession is speaking to...
It's a newly constituted
kind of religious identity,
and vocational career,
and that it's designed to satisfy
new clienteles and followers, migrants,
proletariats in the city,
professionalized middle classes,
even educated globalized elites.
And so there's this
sense of spirit mediums
as these religious entrepreneurs
who are trafficking and
providing often stigmatized
form of worldly prosperity religion.
People talk about them as
leaders of prosperity cults.
Peter Jackson had put spirit mediums
along with other kinds of
figures who led prosperity cults
in the '80s and '90s and beyond
and he's written about that.
And basically, when this second generation
tries to conceptualize spirit possession
in relation to Southeast Asian Buddhism,
they talk about syncretism still,
although there's more
tensions and anxiety about it,
so I see it as sort of thinking about
fractious inclusive syncretism.
It doesn't seem to fit
as neatly as it used to,
and some of them jettison
the idea of syncretism,
and want to talk about
other things like hybridity,
Pattana Kitiarsa's
Scholarship focuses on that.
But the way spirit possession
is now seen as situated
inside of Southeast Asian Buddhism
is that it's sort of incorporating,
and using normative Buddhist
beliefs and practices
to justify their existence,
a kind of Buddhacization of possession.
And therefore there's more
discussion about idiosyncratic,
or unorthodox and even heterodox ways
that spirit mediums act
with regards to Buddhist
beliefs and practices.
Marjorie Muecke has this famous essay
where she documents three monks
who are essentially
students of a spirit medium
and act, very clearly sort of
defer in terms of authority
to the spirit medium.
And there's more discussion
about how there's this
tension and conflict
between spirit mediums and Buddhist monks,
as well as the Sangha and
the mainstream Buddhism,
and spirit mediums are seen
as sort of speaking back,
and criticizing the Sangha and monks,
and sometimes mainstream Buddhists.
So in all these ways,
this second generation of
work on spirit possession
in Buddhist Southeast Asia has emphasized
the way it strains the image
of this kind of uncontested
hegemonic inclusive syncretism,
and that it strains the image
that they're just a specialized niche
providing unique but
relatively marginal services
because they are providing
a wider set of services
that are more conventional and mainstream.
And that clearly this idea
of a segregated, structural opposition
between spirit mediums and
monks is seen as questionable,
or sort of faltering.
So then we come to the third
generation of scholarship,
which is where I see
the contributions to
this book being placed,
and my trope I'm not totally
happy with it I'm interested.
- [Woman] That's what we're hearing now.
- [Woman] Oh, that's
what we're hearing, okay.
- It is multiple spirit
possessions as alternative pieties
within Buddhist Southeast Asia.
So that's basically where I would place
the works in this volume.
They I think foreground.
- Everybody bear with us
as we try to figure out
what happened to Eric's connection.
I'll send him a brief
email, just one second.
- [Erick] And there's also this sense
that they're engaged with
more than just monks.
Usually the discussion was
always about spirit mediums,
and monks relation to each other,
but they're also seen
interacting with state brokers,
and civil society, churches.
They are now also are
even more deeply engaged
with, like, culture industries,
like footprint and digital
mass media and social media.
They use social media to fan,
and preserve their entourages
and to reach out to clientele,
for families, the rituals
they take part in,
and that actually sometimes
there's even another element that's new
is their social organization
becomes even more complex.
A lot of their articles
talk about how there was temporarily
that kind of effort to
create an (indistinct).
With formal kinds of positions
and authority and religions
that it's apart for various readings
that you can read the article about.
And there's even cases of...
Another thing that scholars have noticed,
there's cases of sort of
role of spirit mediums
and Buddhist monks actually
collapsing into each other.
There's more documentation of individuals
who ordained temporarily
as monks, but who are,
and have been spirit mediums in the past
and the complicated way they negotiate
that kind of wearing both of those hats,
even if only temporarily.
And a final element that you
see a lot of the scholarship
is that there's a sense that
(indistinct) and possession
and position like behavior
actually extends beyond just self-identity
identified with spirit mediums,
but that you find other
actors including monks,
whether it's those visions or
dreams or translate behavior,
they're doing things that echo
what sort of looks like possession,
and has possession like qualities.
And they valorize it.
They give it different
terms and languages,
but there's a kind of similarity.
And so basically analytically,
the other thing that these
new scholarship looks at
that you find in this book
is that scholars are
situating spirit mediums
and spirit possession in relation
to vernacular Buddhist beliefs
and practices on the ground,
rather than the official
literary Buddhisms
that are conveying canonical
establishment, or elite voices.
So there's sort of more round and room
for (indistinct)
possession to sort of claim
a kind of value and legitimate based on.
And the other thing (indistinct) analytics
is that again are...
In the past, it was only
thinking about things
in relation to like monks and
the Sangha, and/or the state,
but a lot of attention is
paid to the way they relate
to market in terms of
commercialism and commodities.
The way they relate to civil society
in terms of culture industries, media,
academics, academic
scholarships, associations,
cultural heritage, and tourism.
So the broadening of the sense
of how spirit possession
and spirit medium's side
of the larger social terrain beyond that.
So the final point I'm
gonna make, essentially,
when it comes to conceptualizing
spirit possession,
and Southeast Asian
Buddhism in this generation,
or this third generation,
people don't talk about syncretism,
but there's a lot of anxiety about it,
and how to characterize it.
I've added adjectives when I
read people's scholarships,
sometimes they seem to be talking about,
like, siloed forms of syncretism,
or Fisher forms of syncretism,
or competitive forms of syncretism.
Others have started to
try to reach for language
like polytrophy or creolization
as they continue to struggle to make sense
of how spirit possession fits
in the side of a Buddhist
dominated kind religious world.
And so actually, there's
been this growing sense
that like the conventional way
of dividing up the religious
world that's mixed together
is too limited, right?
You can't just think about
Buddhism and Brahmanism, and (indistinct)
there's other elements,
whether (indistinct)
number of other kinds of ways
of thinking about influences,
and religious traditions
that sort of make up the
total mix and push forward.
That also opens up ways in
which where they locate.
In the first series for the scholars,
all located spirit possession
inside of sort of animism,
which was the most subordinated element,
but now you can see how spirit mediums
and spirit possession can set
inside of a lot of other kinds
of visions of religious
tracing and practice
that would expand the horizons
of what this composite
Southeast Asian Buddhist world
looks like historically.
So the final point that I would make
is that all of this is to say
that amongst these most current scholars
of spirit possession that
you will find in this book,
for them it's much more difficult
to claim that spirit
possession and spirit mediums
are so easily or effectively
dominated, constrained,
subordinated, peripheralized,
for the marginal overarching
Buddhist social order,
because they have been encountering
more and more spirit mediums
who themselves are
pushing back against that
and claiming that if ever you
get inside, that you belong
inside that world as
good, proper Buddhists.
(indistinct)
And so a lot of the spirit
mediums that I've encountered,
and then the scholars
and self-studying that
end up taking positions quite different
from the first generation of scholar.
The parameters of how to
(indistinct) spirit possession
in Southeast Asia.
So I'll end it there, sorry.
- Great. Thank you, Erick.
And thank you for responding
to the technical difficulty,
and continuing with the end of the talk.
I really appreciate that.
So what we'll do now is
we'll open it up to Q&A
for a little bit.
Can I ask everyone when you say your Q&A,
just make sure that Erik was able
to hear the question clearly
once you've completed,
just to make sure
that have a clear line of
communication going here.
Are there any hands who
would like to go first
with a question?
- I'm back.
- Oh, you're back.
- Okay. I'm gonna kill the phone.
I'm getting a rebound from it.
- Okay. Erik what-
- So Thomas Bocha and then
Janet Hoskins, after that,
go ahead.
- Erick, can you hear me?
- Yeah, I can hear you good.
- Great. Thank you.
Thanks for the talk,
super helpful, actually,
to think about the kind
of the scope of the study.
I have two questions.
One is thinking about the second
generation of scholarship,
as you described it,
all sorts of language of innovation anew
and transformation anew, anew, anew.
And I'm wondering to what degree
there's something really new happening?
And to what degree do we
actually just see people
paying attention to what's
been going on for a long time
and the first generation of the...
The pre 1965 and the first
generation of scholars
just ignored it or didn't
realize it was going on,
or what have you.
The second question.
And it really points to...
It's really about the third generation
or the contemporary spirit mediums
in Mainland Southeast Asia,
Nathan Kaplan's book on
"Monastic Education in Korea"
points to really interesting ways
in which Korean Buddhists in
their institutional structures
are clearly reading European
and American scholarship
and histories of Buddhist studies.
And it informs Buddhist education in Korea
in very interesting ways.
And so there's this feedback loop.
And I'm wondering to what
degree do we see spirit mediums
in contemporary Thailand, for example,
how much are they aware of the scholarship
that you've just been talking about?
Do they know about it
or is it something that's
not visible to them.
Thanks very much.
- Okay. Great questions.
So the first one, I think it is...
Part of the distinctiveness
between the first and
the second generation
is they're different
generations of anthropologists
so they're bringing different
assumptions and techniques,
you see a lot more attention
to like cultural politics
and historical dynamics
and historical ethnography
in the second generation that
wasn't there in the first.
And there is also this sense of...
A lot of these second
generation anthropologists,
they've migrated from
studying rural peasant society
to other kinds of social domains.
So part of the newness is that
they're looking anew, right?
I have not been able to find
any sustained ethnographic
studies of religion
in Chiang Mai or Bangkok,
that really sort of attend in much...
That are actually set in
that earlier generation
from '65 to '85,
there aren't that many anthropologists
doing work in urban areas, texture.
Anthropologists doing work
in urban areas, texture.
I mean, there's a bit here and there,
and you can see little suggestive echos
of what the second generation discovers.
So I am quite certain
that it was there to a certain
degree previously, right?
And one way I do know that
is there were some Japanese
skull anthropologists
who did their traditionally,
amazingly, like empirically
detailed studies
of religion in Bangkok.
And I finally got their
work translated into English
and I could tell from the visuals,
and they were doing work...
The work I have is from the 70s
and they're clearly discussing
religious and social forms
organized around possession
that are echoes of what
the scholars are finding
from like the 80s on, they
don't look exactly the same.
They're precursors
that have their own kind of like dynamics.
They seem to be coming
out of urban Chinese
popular religiosity in Bangkok as much.
So that suggests that in that case,
it wasn't because the
ideas were transmitted
from like the rural society and reworked,
it's coming from an
different kind of odd talk
and indigenous source
that the prior generations
of anthropologists
just tended not to see
because they weren't
doing work in urban areas.
So there's something deaf in only there,
but the documentary evidence
is pretty fragmented
and not very extensive,
but I assume what you're
suggesting is true,
and similarly, we actually sort of get
a decreasing sense of these questions
in terms of rural society
in the 80s and the 90s
among Western scholar anthropologists,
because they're doing the same kinds
of intense studies there.
So we can't even track how it's
changing in the rural areas.
In the third generation,
you have more scholars like
Benjamin Bowman and others
looking at possession in rural areas,
in the wake of all these
transformations and reimaginings,
and seeing things
colliding in ways, right?
And in terms of that kind
of whether mediums...
So most of the spirit
mediums I've ever encountered
in my work from the 90s on in Bangkok,
that's where I did my research.
They're not particularly
fluent in English.
So the degree that they get
access to academic models,
it's because they're reading
Thai language popular press,
which often will draw
on Thai anthropologists
who are studying religion
and contemporary society,
and maybe even possession.
And those Thai scholars
have been informed by those seminal works
by the first generation of
foreign scholars, right?
Or even earlier ones like Thai scholars,
like Pra Rajavaramuni
and whatnot like that.
So they're getting it
maybe two or three degrees
of distance and reserve
and mediation, right?
And they're encountering it....
Because they're encountering
in the mass media,
There's much more are
spectacularization and drama
around these kinds of
visions of what it means
to be a spirit medium.
There's not this sort of more
sort of reserve scholarly
kind of annotation and
detail and notation.
So I think some of it is seeping through.
I mean, they're clearly reading...
Spirit mediums I've always encountered,
I mean, they're deeply reading,
like popular mass media
and all this other stuff.
And in fact now,
I didn't talk about the
Thai language scholarship
on spirit mediums,
but I've come across recent
dissertations by Thai monks
who have studied spirit mediums, right?
So there's a complex kind
of conversation going on
between academics and
spirit mediums as well,
being mediated through language and class
and all this other stuff.
And there's a lot of Thai masters students
who have gone out and done
studies of ceremonial cycles
that involve spirit mediums and possession
all over the country
as parts of kind of local
ethnic or territorial identity
and social worlds.
And that's out there and it's
all available for download
digital download now, right?
And so it'd be hard to track,
but I wouldn't be surprised
if this stuff doesn't start reverberating
to the greater degree
that they become literate
in accessing and using
and knowing about this
kind of Scholastic work
about popular religion
and spirit possession,
and mediumship that's
floating around out there.
So thanks for the questions. Yeah.
- Janet, we have a question from you
and then after Janet from Karen Myers.
- Okay. Thank you.
I'd actually like to ask the
same question that you asked me
during discussion Erick.
Why do you think that
the Vietnamese studies
of spirit possession have been siloed.
After I provided one approximate answer,
another one sort of occurred to me,
but I'd rather hear directly
from you what you think.
- Yeah, well, I'll offer up my thoughts
and then I'd be interested
to hear what you think too.
I mean, in general, I
have to be on honest,
the study of religion
in Myanmar, Thailand,
Laos and Cambodia
has tended to not pay attention
to the Vietnamese world.
I mean, across the board.
I think part of it is not seen
as part of this sort of
Theravada majority world.
There are parts of Vietnam that
sort of have that presence.
So it just, hasn't been part
of the training of scholars.
It's more complicated
because clearly there's a
kind of cynic world, right?
A cynic kind of logic
of organizing religion
and popular religion
that's going on there.
And so it's a little more
challenging for scholars
of Mainland Southeast Asia
and Theravada Buddhist majority countries
who have not been exposed
to that kind of scholarship
and ideas and literature,
but it is a problem
and it's kind of ironic
because, it is very common
in the history of Eastern Thai Buddhism
to point to these important figures
who have introduced innovation.
And often it's these it's the Sino ties
who have been sort of negotiating
different religious worlds,
and they have spun out new
ideas inside of Thai Buddhism
and Thai religiosity in general.
So the same logic would
apply to spirit possession
because actually there's
a lot of Thai Buddhists,
even if they're not Sino Thai
who have now...
They're exposed to the
Chinese Pantheon and logics,
and they're claiming that
they're being possessed
by Chinese gods of various
sorts and all of this,
even if they're not Sino Thai
in terms of their own
ethnic origins in history.
And so it would make
sense for Thai scholars
or for scholars of spirit
possession in Thailand
and in the other countries
of Mainland Southeast Asia
to really pay attention
more, not only to Vietnam,
but to the Sinotic kind
of world of religiosity
and how it has influenced
historically in the past
and in the present
what's going on in where they're working.
And it's actually kind of...
I'll be honest.
Like I have diligently collected
as much as the scholarship
on Vietnamese spirit possession
and mediums as I can find,
but I haven't had the
time to dig through it
because in the detail I'd like to.
But it's embarrassing
because between 2005 and now,
there's been an explosion of monographs
and edited volumes that
actually just dwarfs
what's going on in the Mainland Theravada
part of Southeast Asia,
that's been studying
this for decades longer.
And yet as a publishing kind of project,
it has not produced edited
volumes and monographs.
In the same way, there
are very few monographs
focused in a narrow sense,
on spirit possession
and spirit mediumship in
the Theravada majority part
of Mainland Southeast Asia, right?
So I think it's mostly
about training and exposure
and maybe prop language, right?
Like to a certain degree,
it's the usual problem.
Like you'd have to study Vietnamese
and it would be good
to know Chinese as well
to really be able to
make sense of this stuff.
And it's difficult because
of training and constraints.
Were there other thoughts you had that...
- I actually had a different response,
which was more about the influence
of Vietnamese language scholars.
Partly because it was very difficult
to study religion at one point in Vietnam.
And the fact that it
has become more possible
for Vietnamese scholars
and for foreign scholars
is something we owe in part
to a particular folklore
institute run by Nodi Tin
that has been very influential.
But I think what's also true
is that when you talk to people
from other parts of Southeast Asia,
they say, well, the Vietnamese
aren't really as Buddhist
as we are, which may be a
kind of local ethnocentricism,
they're not Theravada Buddhists.
And certainly Buddhism doesn't
have the place in Vietnam
that it has in Thailand.
The place of tremendous power
and sort of central religious influence,
because Buddhism is competing
against many other forms of religiosity.
And one thing that this
folklore institute did
is they labeled spirit possession
as a (speaks in foreign language).
And that in itself makes it in a sense,
independent from Buddhism.
Although there are a lot
of these collaborations
that you're talking about,
and certainly there are monks
who collaborate with spirit
mediums and so forth.
But that has sort of
reconfigured the religious field
in interesting ways.
- Yeah, no, I think that's all true.
And I don't think heritage
and folklore studies
sort of has played the same sort of thing
in the Theravada Mainland world.
And there is something
about the complicated sectarianism, right?
Even in terms of Buddhism, but beyond that
of the religious world of
Vietnam that is confusing
and challenging to scholars
trained to think about religious worlds
that are clearly dominated
by a kind of Theravadian sectarian,
whatever it's local vernacularization,
a singular Theravadian and
kind of orthodoxy, right?
So I think that's part
of it too. Yeah, thanks.
- Karen. You can go ahead.
- Okay. Thanks.
Thanks for that talk.
I really appreciated
the literature review.
I work more in Tibetan Buddhism,
but so I was curious as to
how much of the literature,
you talked a little bit
about cross-cultural analysis
between these Southeast Asian countries,
but how much of the
literature really engages?
I mean, it's a worldwide phenomena, right?
Spirit possession.
And if you could cite any works
that really engage in
that comparative question
in a robust way?
- Well, I have to say,
I've always been surprised
that scholars working on spirit possession
in Theravada Buddhist Southeast Asia
have not tended to look outside the region
and the sectarian orders
the way I would've imagined.
Again, I have large
collections of scholarship
on possession in Tibetan Buddhism
and even China and India.
Especially Sri Lanka.
I gotta say, that's the
most striking thing.
Most scholars working
on spirit possession,
In Myanmar or Thailand, Cambodia,
they never think about the Sri Lanka case,
which is just so obvious.
John Holt has seen this book
and he was kind of like,
"Where's Sri Lanka in this project?"
And I was like,
well, they envisioned
it in a regional sense.
So they didn't go there
but there's another reason.
For whatever reason,
it's just that linguistic
cultural zone and training thing.
They just don't seem to look there.
Again, just like in Vietnam,
there's a large body of
monographs and volumes
and other stuff about spirit
possession in Sri Lanka.
And yet I don't find
scholars thinking about it.
I try to think about it,
but honestly, it's I think...
I don't know.
And then going beyond that,
I mean, spirit possession looks different.
Like in India it looks very
different in Tibet, right?
And then I mean, like East
Asia is another world, right?
You could have a interesting
comparative volume
about how spirit possession
is configured differently in these regions
and the sectarian traditions.
And I hope people try to sort of open up
those kinds of conversations and projects,
because I think it would be very fruitful
and would energize the
study to see the kinds of...
I mean, I've taken part
in these sort of these
workshops on Buddhism
that's had been run in Paris
and that kind of cross-sectarian,
cross-regionalism
has been very instructive
and informative for me
thinking about what I'm seeing
on the ground in the present,
but also what people have talked
about in terms of the past,
in terms of Mainland South
East Asia and/or Thailand.
So you contact me sort of
I'd have to stop and think
about the scholarship
that actually does try
to make those sorts of connections.
Honestly, a lot of the anthropologists
have been only intermittently
engaged with...
There's a whole body of
concepts, analytical,
theoretical work about
just spirit possession
inside of anthropology.
And it hasn't had a
very significant impact
for the most part.
It's interesting.
I sometimes Thai study
scholars have drank the Koolaid
of a kind of exceptionalism
a little too much,
and it's sort of made them
inoculated against doing that.
But so I'm not sure why,
so there's a lot of other right
kinds of theoretical works
either coming out of other regions.
And I would say the introduction
by Peter and Benedicte
does try to engage with
some of this stuff,
think critically about how that absence
has influenced past
scholarship and our approaches.
They don't sort of rectify
the problem, but they note.
I mean, they basically argue
that there is a Southeast
Asian possession complex,
and I agree and disagree with them
in certain ways about that.
But they're basically like
let's think about regional possession
in terms of like different kinds
of regionalized kind of complexes
that have a different distinct kind
of historical and social logics.
And they suggest that scholars
working on Buddhi Southeast
Asia start thinking like that.
So there are efforts to
sort of push that way,
but it's not clear
how much it'll be taken
up by future scholars.
- Yeah. Thank you.
It seems because one of the questions
is how does it relate to Buddhism?
And so we could look at
other Buddhist cultures,
but also non Buddhist cultures
that have spirit possession
to get a sort of broader perspective.
- Actually, your comment makes me say,
so the earliest scholars laid down
these kinds of foundational
sort of frames and assumptions,
and the fact that the
the earliest scholars,
Spiro and Tambiah and Kirsch
were working with this sort of issue
of great traditions, little
traditions, and Buddhism
and localization and all of that,
that has tended to then sort of close out
other kinds of optics and horizons
and made scholars a little content.
Later, generations of scholars
just sort of not see analytic
and theoretical possibilities
because they're like,
that's the big issue?
How does spirit possession fit
inside of Buddhist logics and actors
and the Buddhist religious field.
But what about all these
other kinds of questions?
They tend to be just sort of...
They aren't the are not on the horizon
and so scholars don't
always sort of see them.
They don't jump out at them.
- Yeah. Thank you.
And I did sort of frame it
in terms of that particular
line of argument.
- This is really great.
Karen, I wanted to thank
you for that question
because it's inspired me to
talk to some of my colleagues
across the different area councils.
Where Southeast Asian
studies with my colleagues
in East Asian studies
and South Asian studies
and other places too
interested in these kinds of questions.
And then I always think,
well, we have some initiatives
to think of a kind of
trans-regional Buddhist studies,
but it also makes us maybe need
to rethink that too, right?
There's certainly great reason to do that,
but to think
maybe the transnational
spirit possession studies
or something would be a really interesting
kind of framework as well.
I said that Tak had a question,
but in fact, he was waving to one of us.
So I don't want force
him to have a question,
but knowing Tak, he always
has a good question to ask.
So I'll give you the opportunity, Tak,
if you wanna take up the offer.
- Actually, I was waiting at Rick Roof.
Anyway, the, the question
I had was already answered
because when listening to all this,
I was thinking about spirit
procession in Southeast Asia.
And the other place that a
lot of studies have been made
is actually the Philippines.
And so I was gonna ask Erick,
whether instead of talking
about just Buddhism,
if he could talk about spirit possession
and the Philippines is an
interesting case, right?
It's Catholic or non-Catholic.
- It is, right for the broader...
But again for, I think scholars
working in mainland Southeast
Asia, they're intimidated.
When you go to the insular world,
it's not just social,
cultural, political logics,
an organization would be different,
but then you're encountering
Islam and Christianity, right?
In a certain sense as these
world historical traditions.
And there is a sense that
monotheistic traditions
have treated spirit
possessions slightly different
than non monotheist traditions,
have been less accommodating often.
At least, scholarships
tend to suggest that.
So it's not like things
couldn't be learned,
but I think again, they
see it as a little...
I think it would be an easier step up
to look at like possession
in the Chinese world
and in the Vietnamese world
and in the south Asian world
to the degree
that they're in this
sort of non monotheistic
dominated kind of religious orders.
And it's another step up
then to take into account
what's going on with spirit possession
when you're in a Christian
or an Islamic kind of world
that has often seems have
stronger prohibitions
to exclude it, right?
Despite early scholars
thinking that spirit possession
is this subordinated
marginal sort of thing.
It's recognized by Buddhists
and it is accommodated and
tolerated in certain ways.
Except for some of the most high modernist
kinds of Thai or Buddhist
or Myanmar Buddhists
who denounce it thoroughly.
But there's a kind of
accepting accommodation of it,
which can sometimes seem to be harder
in certain kinds of Christian and Muslim
kinds of environments.
So it would definitely be...
Especially if we wanna work
the regional kind of character.
If Benedicte and Peter are talking
about a Southeast Asian
sort of possession complex,
they are mostly thinking about
it in terms of the Mainland,
They haven't expanded that
horizon to the insular world,
which would introduce certain
kinds of complexities.
Thanks.
- I received a note
from Rick Ruth who got the
spirit of the wave from Tak
and now wishes to answer
a question as well.
- I'm sorry. Yeah, yeah.
Just actually two things really quick.
First of all, I wanna
had to wish Erick White
a happy birthday (laughs).
I did remember it was your birthday
and thank him for doing this.
And actually I was
thinking a lot maybe about,
in some ways we've been
talking about blending,
what we've seen as Asian American studies
with regional studies.
A lot lately, I noticed
more and more departments
are combining or considering 'em together.
And this afternoon we've been
talking about in some ways,
the geographical siloing, I guess,
between Vietnam and Thailand
and the Philippines.
Now, what I've felt myself wondering
is in terms of diasporic studies,
are there studies of spirit
medium even specifically
Thai Kun Sojao turning
up in the United States.
I mean, in our lifetime,
in this kind of half century
that you've described,
we've seen Thai world appearing
in more and more states
across the country as
part of that manifestation
of Southeast Asian religion
in North America or in Europe,
are there Kun Sojao in the United States,
are there anthropologists studying?
- So interestingly,
I'm not sure I know the literature
as well as I could or should,
and I think off the top of my head,
it's in terms of the diaspora in America,
and it's interestingly,
I have seen analyses of spirit possession
in sort of Southeast
Asian diasporic America
in the Cambodian and the Laosian worlds
because of the demographics
of refugees and migration, right?
I wouldn't be surprised
if it's not popping up
in Burmese and Thai worlds as well,
but I've seen a few pieces of
scholarship, but not a lot.
So it is sort of...
There is a touch of that,
but I've never seen anything
about spirit possession
amongst ethnic ties
outside of South East Asia
or the extended sort of world
on the borderlands, for instance.
- So maybe this is somewhere
where then a fourth generation
can go with it then, or-
- Yeah, I mean, that's
certainly one direction.
I mean, there's so many
different directions.
I talk about issues and
directions in my afterword
and Peter and Benedicte talk
about it as well in their book,
I think actually, ironically,
in relation to what Janet
was talking about or Karen,
there's actually a sense
of going more intensely
into the Southeast Asian world,
which is to say,
increasingly scholars are
pushing back on the idea
of, okay, so there's this common
kind of Theravada Buddhist
religious logic
across all of mainland
Southeast Asia, right?
But they're like, if you
look at the pantheons,
the pantheons don't look the same,
the pantheons of possessing
spirits don't look the same
across the countries and
even regions within country.
And you can see the language
and even the kinds of the
styles and kind the modalities
of spirit possession that are valorized
and worth cultivating,
they don't look the same
across these different worlds.
So there's actually a increasingly a sense
that we have to pay more attention
to actually the historical
and social specificity
of what these religious
worlds and fields look like
underneath the umbrella
of the nation state,
which tends to sort of
artificially homogenize everything
much less the umbrella of Theravada
which it can even more
powerfully homogenize everything.
And there's a sense that actually,
you've got very localized pantheons
that are kind of open ended
and generatively playing.
And Paul Sorrentino's article
about out Vietnamese spirit possession
in the edited volume
goes into great detail
about sort of the creative
ambiguities and slippages
within the Vietnamese Pantheon
that has allowed spirit possession
to take on these different
shapes over from the colonial era
to the modern era and
actually jostling with visions
of what the Pantheon
is and who's in and out
and the logics of interacting with them.
But the same thing, I think, applies
to the local Theravada Buddhist worlds
of possession and mediumship
across the rest of
Mainland Southeast Asia.
That's a totally different angle
instead of sort of going out,
it's even going deeper to
really sort of pay attention
to local history and society
and culture and politics
and how it has shaped things
so that it's not like, all
spirit mediumship looks the same
from Mandalay to Phnom Penh,
to low Angkor Ban right?
- Well, this brings us to 1:30.
So I think I'm gonna bring
the formal part of our
discussion to a close
and I'll stop the recording,
but please join me in a round
of applause for Erick's talk.
And you're welcome to linger a little bit
for informal chitchat for a few moments.